what if everything in the universe was
actually a bit to the right of where it
is now or if this orbiting planet was
actually half a rotation ahead
what changes more importantly what stays
the same
these seem like fun but useless thought
experiments until Emmy Noether
discovered what I think is the most
profound and far-reaching idea in
physics knowing what happens to a system
under these imaginary transformations
gives us insight into the system's real
behavior
the usual summary is symmetries imply
conservation laws in this video I'll
explain what that means
we'll start with symmetry normally we
use the word symmetry to mean that if we
took the mirror image along some line a
symmetric object looks the same mirror
symmetries like these are pretty but we
can make the word symmetry means so much
more
for example rotational symmetry when you
can rotate an object by a certain amount
and it looks just the same as before or
another example is translational
symmetry in fact mathematicians took the
idea of symmetry and generalized it
completely a symmetry is anything where
you have some sort of object and apply
some sort of transformation to it and
you can't tell the difference in some
sense this might seem like they've taken
a good descriptive word and then
generalized it until it's meaningless
but actually this idea is very useful
these abstract symmetries are a
constantly reoccurring theme in
mathematics in fact the study of
symmetry helped motivate one of the most
important fields of modern mathematics
called abstract algebra Emmy Noether was
an expert in symmetry having developed
foundational concepts in abstract
algebra it was during a small pause from
her extremely influential mathematical
career that she thought about physics
she wondered if she could apply the idea
of symmetry to the world and that's what
led her to her beautiful theorem this is
the symmetry that she considered the
object is some system a part of the
universe it could be a thing someone's
throwing or a particle in a void or
maybe some binary stars or if you want
the whole universe then you transform it
for example you could rotate it by some
angle lambda or shift it up or down by
lambda or stretch all the distances by
lambda now we're interested in if this
system is the same in some sense northa
decided the interesting thing to check
is if the total energy of the objects
would be the same so we say that a
system has a symmetry under a
transformation if the total energy of
the objects didn't change after that
transformation for example if I had a
particle all by itself and then compared
it to a shifted version clearly the
energies are the same so this system is
translationally symmetric on the other
hand say there was some big planet
nearby a particle that is closer has got
more gravitational potential energy and
so this isn't translationally symmetric
or consider this object orbiting in a
circle and compare it to a rotated
version both objects are an equal
distance from the planet and so both
ways they have the same gravitational
potential energy and so this system is
rotationally symmetric so that's the
symmetry part of know--this theorem now
let's look at conservation x'
if you've ever studied physics for
example at school you'll know how
important these things called
conservation laws are it means that if
you have a bunch of things and you count
it up their total momentum let's say
then you let them go for any amount of
time and countered the momentum again it
would be the same number
technically you can do physics without
ever needing to use these conservation
laws but sometimes you'll be given some
insane problem that looks like you
shouldn't be able to solve at least not
very easily but if you invoke the
magical conservation laws your answer
just falls out conservation laws aren't
just useful in classical physics either
they help out in quantum mechanics and
really all of modern physics I used to
not like using conservation laws because
they can make it seem too easy as in I
get this
solution with so little work that it
really felt like magic and so I didn't
feel like I understood why it worked
after all I didn't understand why energy
is conserved or why momentum is
conserved and so if I used one of those
to solve a problem then clearly I didn't
understand the solution note this
theorem is powerful because it tries to
explain where conservation come from so
let me go back to an example I said that
momentum is conserved but this is kind
of not always true if I trace my system
to be a ball rolling on the ground we
all know that eventually it stops or if
I drop something it gets faster and
faster sure if you take everything as
your system then momentum is always
conserved but how can I know whether a
particular systems mentum won't change
no --this theorem gives us a simple way
to know regardless of whether the system
is one particle or the whole universe
she proves that you only get
conservation x' if the system had the
right symmetries again let's look at
examples if you have translational
symmetry the theorem says that you have
conservation of momentum we know that a
particle that's on its own has this
symmetry and so its momentum is
conserved and we know that's true it
will continue on at the same speed in
the same direction forever if we instead
had a bunch of particles by themselves
as our system this system is also
translationally symmetric if they were
all over there instead that doesn't
change their energy so again Nothe tells
us that we have conservation of their
total momentum which wouldn't be that
obvious otherwise in fact if we
considered a shifted over version of the
entire universe no one would be able to
tell the difference and so there's
clearly no difference in the energy
hence the momentum of the whole universe
is conserved when isn't momentum
conserved for a system what about this
object that gains speed as it falls note
this theorem says that this system can't
have translational symmetry so let's
check what if this object was nearer to
the ground
it would have less gravitational
potential energy good
so it isn't symmetric what about
rotational symmetry like we said this
object could have been rotated here and
the energy wouldn't change and so it has
rotational symmetry about this axis we
also know it has angular momentum in
this direction and that it goes at the
same speed the whole way around and so
it's angular momentum is constant in
other words conserved and this is what
know--this Theron predicts that if you
have rotational symmetry about one axis
then the angular momentum in that
direction is conserved so one last
example and this one is a weird one
we've talked about translating in space
and in angle but what about translating
in time in other words you have a system
doing something at a particular moment
and then you compare it to the same
system sometime later if it has the same
energy then it is time translation
symmetric
what does Nothe say is conserved then
it's the energy I know that's a bit
circular here but it's more important
when we come to quantum mechanics so I
had to mention this one Noether didn't
just come up with these three examples
instead she gave us a mathematical way
to turn any symmetry into a conservation
and vice-versa
see these conserved quantities are
called the generators of these
transforms and you can calculate what
the generator is for any transformation
that you come up with if I encountered
some exotic system and noticed it was
symmetric under some transformation
there is a mathematical way for me to
calculate what's conserved there's also
a converse say I noticed some mysterious
new quantity is conserved in some system
I'm interested in no this theorem says
that that conservation is from some
symmetry and the conserved quantity is
the generator of that transformation so
I can calculate what that transformation
was that's very powerful but the theorem
is amazing because it is just as
beautiful as it is useful symmetries
appeal to us and seem natural we think
it makes sense that if the
universe was shifted or rotated that
nothing should change there's no
difference between here and there so
showing that symmetry and conservation
laws are equivalent shows that
conservation laws must be just as
natural homework this time is pretty
gentle I want you to let me know what
you think of this idea have you heard of
it before maybe you've heard about
things like supersymmetry in physics try
and find out how that's related to this
the version of know--this theorem I
talked about here is the one for
classical physics only a much less
powerful version of the theorem than the
one that she actually created if you
know some calculus and classical physics
maybe try and find one of the priests
for this theorem and this is a fun
activity try and come up with strange
systems with strange symmetries and see
if you can figure out what's conserved